hello and welcome to med simplified
the human excretory system is one of the
most important organ systems of the body
that performs the vital function of
filtering your blood and removing
excessive and unnecessary materials from
the body
this helps to maintain an internal
chemical homeostasis and prevent damage
to the body
in this video we are going to study
about the human excretory system
in a narrow sense the term refers to the
urinary system however as excretion
involves several other organs it is
important to remember that human
excretory system is a wide term that
also includes organs like skin
lungs gut nails and hair
in this video we will first learn about
the urinary system and then we will
discuss about the other organs that are
involved in the process of excretion
before beginning if you are new to this
channel make sure to click on the
subscribe button below to get all the
upcoming scribe educational videos and
also if you find the content of this
channel helpful you can now support med
simplified on patreon.com for the price
of a coffee cup that will allow me to
make more free educational videos like
this
all the links are in the description
below and for more information watch
till the end of this video
so let's begin with the urinary system
the urinary system consists of a pair of
kidneys
a pair of ureters
a urinary bladder
and a urethra
the renal artery supplies the kidney
with fresh blood
while the renal vein drains the blood
from the kidneys
we'll go through each of these
structures one by one and understand
their role in the process of excretion
so the main hero of the urinary system
is this pair of kidneys
the kidneys do the main job of filtering
your blood and removing all the waste
substances from it
the rest of the urinary system is
basically just a storage unit and
provides a mechanical force so that the
urine can be expelled from the body
now the kidneys are bean shaped organs
that are present on each side of our
spine almost at the level of our
umbilicus
if you take a look at this specimen you
can note the position of kidneys in the
body i know it's gross but have a look
this is a cut section of the body and
you're looking at it from the top angle
this is the front side of the body and
this is the rear
here is your amplicus and this is your
spine
and here you can note the position of
the kidneys in the body
you can clearly see that the kidneys are
actually present towards the rear or the
posterior aspect of the abdomen
so each kidney measures approximately 11
to 13 centimeters in length with the
left kidney being slightly larger
the right kidney is placed at a lower
level as compared to the left kidney
this asymmetry in size
and placement is due to the position of
liver on the right side of the body
now each kidney has a convex and a
concave border the concave border of the
kidney has this notch-like structure
known as the hilum this is the place
where the blood vessels enter and leave
the kidney
now if we slice the kidney with a knife
in this manner we will able to see this
internal structure of the kidney
the first thing you should note here is
that the internal structure of the
kidney is divided into two major regions
the renal cortex
and the renal medulla
the renal cortex is this outer region of
the kidney while the renal medulla
consists of these 12 to 15
cone-shaped structures known as the
medullary pyramids
the outer renal cortex runs in a
continuous manner with a number of
projections that extend down between the
pyramids
guys you can get the handwritten lecture
handout from this video by joining our
channel
click the join button below to get the
lecture handout from this video as well
as our previous videos
now like i told you
this is known as the hilum of the kidney
the point where the blood vessels enter
and leave the kidney
the blood enters the kidney through the
renal artery
after the renal artery enters the kidney
it gets divided into many small branches
these small branches ultimately go to
the cortex area and divide into many
smaller branches known as capillaries
now the cortex region contains the most
number of nephrons in the kidney
the nephron is the basic functional unit
of the kidney and each kidney contains
approximately one million nephrons
this is the main structure that filters
the blood in the kidney
now if you want to learn in detail about
the structure of nephron and the
mechanism of urine formation check out
our this video on the structure of
nephron links are in the description
below
now let's continue with our basic
structure
so we reached a point where the renal
artery has entered the kidney and
divided into many smaller branches which
ultimately divided into minute branches
known as capillaries
each of these capillaries enter the
nephron and form a tuft of blood vessels
in this cup shaped structure known as
the bowman's capsule
and it is in this cup shape structure
that the filtration of blood takes place
here you can see in a magnified view how
the capillary enters the nephron and
forms a tuft of blood vessels that
filters the blood
the blood enters the nephron through
this vessel and leaves it via this
vessel
the waste products and water leave the
blood into the nephron and the pure
blood exits through this blood vessel
all of this pure blood comes out of the
kidney through small blood vessels which
ultimately drain into the renal vein
so this stuff was happening right here
in the nephron
all the filtered stuff is passed down
into this small tube-like structure now
see how urine is formed here if you look
at this illustration you can note how a
single nephron is placed inside the
kidney
the waste metabolic products and water
that is filtered by the nephrons enters
the medulla of the kidney through small
ducts known as the collecting ducts
all these collecting ducts converge at
the tip of the renal medulla which is
known as the papilla
these collecting ducts drain the waste
products and water into this central
dilated part of the kidney which is
known as a renal calyx
now what does this word calyx mean well
if you remember calyx is actually a part
of a flower
this is known as the calyx of a flower
if you look at the shape of a calyx of a
flower you can see why this part of the
kidney is known as the renal calyx
the renal calyx receives the urine from
each of the renal medullary pyramid and
ultimately drains all of this urine into
the
ureter so moving forward with the
structure of the urinary system
the urine that is formed in the kidneys
is passed down with the help of these
structures which are known as the
ureters
uraters are 25 to 30 centimeter long
tubes that exit the kidney through the
hilum and they run down into the urinary
platter
the walls of the ureters have smooth
muscles in them that help to propel the
urine forward from the kidneys into the
urinary bladder
now a kidney stone can move from the
kidney and become lodged inside the
ureter which can block the flow of urine
as well as cause a sharp cramp like pain
in the back side or the lower abdomen
this type of pain is known as a renal
colic
next the urine moves from the ureters
into the urinary platter the urinary
bladder is a hollow organ that is
present in the pelvis
the wall of the urinary bladder is a
muscular wall and it is a distensible
structure meaning it can stretch
now a typical human bladder will hold
between 300 to 500 milliliters of urine
before the urge to empty occurs but it
can hold considerably more if you don't
find a place to pee immediately
the urine enters the bladder through two
ureters and leaves the bladder through
the urethra
which is another tube-like structure
that we will discuss in just a bit
now this part of the bladder is known as
the body of the bladder and the part
below it is known as the neck of the
bladder
the neck of the bladder is very
important it is basically this part of
the bladder that make sure that you
don't leak urine all the time
the neck of the bladder contains a ring
of smooth muscles that remains
contracted and keeps the opening of the
bladder closed
whenever we want to pass urine the nerve
supplying the neck of the bladder
relaxes the smooth muscles here which
allows the urine to pass from the
bladder into the urethra
this ring of smooth muscles is known as
a sphincter of the bladder
so our kidneys keep producing urine
which is carried by the ureters into the
urinary platter the urinary bladder
provides two important functions for the
urinary system
first it provides a hollow organ that is
used to store urine this is a very
important function because you can
imagine what running for the toilet
every 10 minutes would look like
second the urinary bladder is a muscular
organ the contractions of the muscles in
the wall of the bladder provide the
force by which urine is expelled through
the body
the urine exits the bladder through the
urethra
urethra is another hollow tube-like
structure that helps to expel the urine
out of the body
as the passage needs to traverse the
length of the penis it is significantly
longer in males than females
it is approximately 4 centimeter in
length for females whereas it is about
20 centimeters in length in the male
body
this is the reason why females have
urinary tract infections more frequent
than men
besides excretion the kidney has
many other important roles like
maintaining a proper volume of fluids in
the body
maintaining a proper balance between the
levels of different types of ions in our
body
maintaining a proper ph of the body
regulation of the blood pressure
and formation of important vitamins like
vitamin d
so this was about the role of urinary
system in the process of excretion now
let's talk about the rest of the organs
of the body that are included in the
human excretory system
and the first one of them is your skin
sweat glands in the skin secrete a fluid
waste called sweat or perspiration
however its primary function is
temperature control and pheromone
release
therefore its role as a part of
excretory system is minimal
sweating also maintains a level of salt
in the body sweat is mostly water
dissolved in the water are trace amounts
of minerals lactic acids and urea
many other trace elements are also
excreted in sweat like chromium copper
nickel zinc and lead
the large intestines main function is to
transport food particles through the
body and expel the indigestible parts at
the other end but it also collects waste
from throughout the body the typical
brown color of mammal waste is due to
bilirubin a breakdown product of normal
heme catabolism
at about 10 feet long in humans it
transports a waste through the tubes to
be excreted
the respiratory system also plays a role
in the process of excretion as lungs
expel out gaseous waste like carbon
dioxide
the liver is an important organ that
helps in excretion of many drugs
liver metabolizes these drugs and their
waste products are passed into bile
the yellowish liquid that is formed in
the liver and delivered to the small
intestine it is through this bile that
the liver excretes many waste products
like metabolites of drugs and heavy
metals
apart from these nails and hair are also
considered a part of the excretory
system as many heavy metals are excreted
in the nails and hair
now like we discussed previously in this
video for you to have a complete
understanding about the process of urine
formation and the function of kidney you
need to watch this video about the
structure and function of nephron this
video explains in detail about the
structure of nephron and how urine is
formed inside the kidneys
i hope you like this video thank you so
much for watching